you and i have bibled and babbled but
today
president-elect joe biden gave a very
emotional speech
as he left to become president to the
people of delaware
you're from delaware did this and you
listened to this speech this must have
had real meaning for you
i just i was just watching it on my
phone right before you got in your chair
and i
almost started crying i mean yeah i love
that man i'm so proud of him i'm so
proud
to be a delawarean and uh i cannot wait
to
for tomorrow and in fact it almost is
tomorrow here
that's right 45 minutes and uh
and uh and i'm just yeah i just his
speech touched me like
he's just a real person and he has a
soul and he has empathy and he
believes in our country and our in our
people and
uh and i'm just my heart is full
no jokes conan no this is the part
that's serious
uh there's no screwing around i take my
glasses off still but
i i mean it like i'm just i'm so
uh you're very happy and because you're
because you're in turkey
biden's going to become president
earlier for you than for us
yeah that doesn't no that's not true um
he you know it's doesn't make any sense
what i just said
you know the turkish people are very
proud of him
right now i can speak for turkey you
know i think you do speak for turkey in
many ways
what says turkey more than aubry plaza
in a robe and sunglasses
in a hotel room that quite frankly could
be here in la i'm just taking your word
for it that you're in turkey
um you've done nothing to prove that you
were in turkey except show me four
apples in cellophane
how does that prove you're in turkey
don't
tempt me to take my laptop down the
hallway and get into some real trouble
okay i won't we won't do that you know
you talked about delaware
there's a movement in delaware because
you're from there
to change the name of columbus square to
aubrey plaza plaza how do you feel about
that
i support listen google maps has already
officiated this if you look on google
maps where the columbus statue used to
be
it does say the aubrey plaza plaza i
didn't do it
that's great i didn't ask for this but
if
if the people want to give it to me i
won't let them down i'll come up with
the right you know
person to put on that block of cement
and it and it won't be you know
someone shitty that's an eloquent speech
about what should happen in that space
i'll work on my speech
if you do end up giving a speech there
please yeah you'll
you'll get there